eh bien
bonjour tout le monde je vais vous
parler effectivement de calcul et de
modélisation
on va commencer par modélisation qu'est
ce que veut dire modélisation on a la
prétention de mettre en général le monde
en équation donc la modélisation c'est
premièrement de faire des équations et
alors si on relit la modélisation au
calcul mais aux machines de calcul on
arrive à une activité aujourd'hui qui
est devenue prépondérante dans le monde
de l'industrie qui est la simulation
numérique
j'ai commencé par montrer quelques
exemples de simulation numérique pour
des choses appliquée alors ces exemples
sont pris
dans les exemples de mon équipe mais il
y en a beaucoup plus par ailleurs mais
on peut calculer des matériaux calculs
et des écoulements autour d'avions
d'hélicoptères de formule 1 tels que les
des matériaux composites et tout ça
c'est assez important
prenez une voiture tous les objets qui
nous entourent aujourd'hui sont
fabriqués industriellement vous prenez
une voiture elle a été calculée avant on
prenait un avion
il a été calculé pour voler mais aussi
calculé pour tenir dans qui tiennent
assez souvent ça arrive qui tombe
effectivement mais donc tout ça est
calculé et modéliser donc aujourd'hui la
simulation numérique est devenu quelque
chose qui vous qui est pas qui est
courant mais qui aussi un facteur
important de ba de la compétitivité de
la croissance du monde de l'amélioration
de toutes choses
alors d'où vient cette affaire au départ
si on regarde ce que c'est que le calcul
ben c'est un peu la naissance des
mathématiques des mathématiques
au départ on a dû commencer par comté et
puis vite additionner donc en fait
de là sont nés les mathématiques mais
ben comme les mathématiques c'est
souvent faire des calculs on a fait avec
les mathématiques des calculs de plus en
plus poussée et est aujourd'hui ce que
je veux discuter c'est l'heureux cerlier
calculé machine de calcul alors si on
revient à mon problème de modélisation
jusqu'à l'avènement des super
ordinateurs ou des ordinateurs simples
on va voir bas modéliser c'était
effectivement mettre en équation un
certain nombre de choses et à partir de
ces équations on essayer de prédire
quelque chose on peut qu'on puisse
sortir une information de ces équations
là les choses ont changé
ces dernières années ces dernières
décennies et simplement en disant bas
maintenant à modi'in mode du un modèle
c'est quelque chose qui doit être
calculable effectivement on peut
simplifier les choses puisque ça va être
un ordinateur qui va faire des calculs
allait essayer de prédire du modèle une
situation est donc ça ça a changé à la
fois la façon de penser des gens qui
font de la physique ou de la mécanique
et de et ça a changé la chose la façon
dont on pourrait voir les choses alors
modélisés et calculé sait prédire et
effectivement on peut compliquer
aujourd'hui les modèles puisqu'on n'a
pas obligation de sortir une solution
directement comme on l'aurait pris
appris à l'école des équations va
pouvoir donner un ordinateur quelque
chose qui est lui va nous faire des
prédictions qui pulse qui peuvent ferme
alors la plupart des modélisations
souvent ce sont des équations dans
lequel on est capable plutôt de dire
comment les choses vont évoluer vers on
part d'un état on le met en équation et
ses équations disent comment les choses
vont évoluer à partir d'un état alors
pourquoi le calcul de re devient très
important et la vitesse de calcul
devient importante il faut quand même
que vous arriviez à calculer des
solutions de vos modèles plus rapidement
que ce qui va arriver par la suite
alors vous avez vu par exemple
l'évolution de lait des prédictions
météo prédictions météo
les météorologues utilisent les
superordinateurs les plus puissants
aujourd'hui pour essayer de prévoir le
temps plus vite que ce qui va arriver
sinon ce ne serait pas très utile donc
c'est un petit peu tout ce jeu qui qui
qui arrive aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle la
simulation numérique
on parle aujourd'hui du troisième pilier
de la science alors effectivement dans
le domaine des sciences comme dans le
domaine de l'ingénierie la simulation
numérique elle est partout bah oui parce
que les
les gens qui font la science en général
font un modèle et le confronte à
l'expérience donc jusqu'à maintenant
c'était modèle et expérience si
l'expérience ne repose si le modèle ne
reproduisez pas l'expérience et bien ont
rejeté ce modèle aujourd'hui on fait
modèle simulation expérience justement
parce que les modèles se deviennent
beaucoup plus sophistiqué on arrive à
faire beaucoup de choses dedans et on va
d'abord essayer de prédire parts et ses
modèles de la simulation numérique et
puis on va voir qu'avec l'avènement des
superordinateurs eh bien on commence à
faire des choses de plus en plus
spectaculaires de bus classique à faire
de la combustion de l'aérodynamique ou
de la fabrication
on en parlait juste avant j'ai des
collègues en suisse qui ont comme projet
aujourd'hui pas de simuler le
fonctionnement d'un cerveau humain donc
et donc on peut aussi avoir des
applications de plus en plus importante
pour l'associer pour la société puisque
là par exemple c'est le calcul
d'écoulement de courant du gulf stream
là aussi on a besoin de calculateurs de
plus en plus puissants alors ce qui est
intéressant de voir maintenance et
l'évolution des choses jusqu'à
maintenant donc je parle de tel qu'une
ma team mathématiques et de machines de
calcul pour faire tout ça on a besoin de
deux machines de calcul est
effectivement cette science de la
simulation numérique s'appuie sur une
industrie qui est relativement récente
et d'industrie informatique et
l'évolution de cette industrie là
jusqu'au début jusqu'au début des années
2000 le monde était assez simple on
avait ce qu'on appelait la loi de moore
qui vous disaient tout simplement que
tous les 18 mois vous allez multiplier
par deux la puissance de calcul de votre
ordinateur simplement la rapidité de
calcul de votre ordinateur
en fait ça c'est une loi qui vient de
l'industrie des de l'industrie
informatique qui était basée sur le fait
que ben quand on a commencé à imprimer
des faire des circuits imprimés et
marans aperçu que tous les 18 membres
pouvaient empilés de plus en plus de
transistors dans le même support de
silicium
donc les choses étaient relativement
simple vous aviez un ordinateur et cet
ordinateur elle est tout simplement dit
deux fois plus vite tous les éléments de
la façon suivante c'est-à-dire vous
aviez un programme est automatiquement
de vous veniez 18 mois + plus tard pour
acheter un ordinateur ils allaient sans
rien changer
ils avaient deux fois plus vite et ça
s'est passé jusqu'au début des années
2000 qui a permis de d'extrapoler donc
c'est une courbe exponentielle
effectivement ici on est en échelle log
ça permettait d'extrapoler et de faire
de la science fiction et effectivement
on prédisait que en 2020 les ordinateurs
seraient tellement puissant qui se
construirait une hummer et qui seraient
encore à capable d'aller encore plus
vite que la loi de mon bon nous sommes
arrivés à une butée physique au début
des années 2000 c'est à dire que cette
partie là est arrivé au bout de son
aventure
alors quand même les années 2000 dans
cette science fiction était très un très
important puisque au début des années
1 vous voyez la progression des
ordinateurs étaient telles que bah on
pense effectivement qu'on remplacerait
le cerveau humain et pour la première
fois le meilleur joueur d'échecs
kasparov a été battu par un ordinateur
donc il faut noter cette révolution à ce
moment là qui a quand même troublé les
esprits puisque on pensait que personne
ne serait plus intelligent qu'un être
humain est là pour la première fois des
bills les ordinateurs battait des êtres
humains mais on était arrivé au bout
d'une technologie c'est à dire que
physiquement on pouvait pas aller plus
vite
alors cette technologie ouvre ce monde
on peut la relier à ce qu'on appelait la
fréquence d'horloge de la fréquence
d'horloge
c'était la cadence et laquelle bas un
ordinateur et donc c'est là que la
cadence avec elle vous pouvez faire une
opération
donc on n'avait qu'une horloge et albat
et et plus elle battait vite plus on
avait on était capable d'aller vite
c'est ce qui se passe est tout
simplement aujourd'hui puis
on a des arts y arrive la fin des années
2000 donc ça c'était une informatique
ont appelé séquentiel cette cadence des
processeurs bas et n'était plus capable
d'évoluer
c'est comme si aujourd'hui bas peut-être
nos coeurs battent et peut-être plus
plus lentement au départ et puis on
arrivait à un fonctionnement optimum et
aujourd'hui nos coeur bat bat toujours
la même vitesse alors naturellement nous
dans l'industrie informatique ou la
simulation numérique
l'idée était de relayer 7 buts et
physique par un autre procédé
donc à partir de ce moment là on a
commencé à dire bas plutôt que d'avoir
un coeur qui bat donc une unité de
calcul on verra on va les multiplier
donc on commence à avoir un deux ou
trois coeurs donc le parallélisme et
c'est ce qu'on appelle le faire du
calcul parallèle et ça ça ça va nous
permettre de continuer la loi de moore
sous une autre forme
alors on a commencé timidement amp l on
appelait ça du calcul pareil et puis
vous allez voir qu'à la fin des années
2010 il y à une accélération on commence
à parler de calculateurs massivement
parallèle par exemple ça veut dire quoi
massivement parallèle on prend la
machine une des machines les plus
puissantes en france machine curie
allait elle a comporte cent mille coeurs
de calcul c'est à dire un coeur de
calcul grosso modo c'est un des
ordinateurs c'est comme si on en avait
essayé on faisait une machine
rassemblant les cent mille ordinateurs
portables que vous avez chez vous donc
c'est à peu près ça la donne
alors si on regarde un petit peu ce qui
se passe même à l'échelle mondiale et
ben voilà on est passé vraiment à
quelque chose de très nouveau
et puis là j'ai marqué j'ai listé les
cinq machines les plus puissantes de la
planète
tout le monde se serait peut-être
attendu à ce que la machine la plus
puissante était aux états unis et non
elle est en chine depuis peu et pour
l'instant elle est un déclin décrochable
puisque ça fait deux ans que la machine
la plus puissante et chinoises
bon dans les cinq premières il ya quand
même trois machines américaines est une
machine japonaise paraît effectivement
et c'est un première vous voyez aucune
machine européenne alors pas tout à fait
si j'avais mis la 6e machine vous auriez
vu que la 6e machine est une machine
européenne
mais de quel pays de la suisse donc
presque européenne alors quand même pour
un petit peu pondérer cet état des lieux
on fait quand même on peut regarder les
choses en faisant une répartition des
plus grosses de l'ordinateur des plus
gros supercalculateurs existant sur la
planète aujourd'hui et on s'aperçoit
quand même que le gros carrés ici chaque
carré représente une machine donc on
s'est arrêté un certain niveau de
machines donc vous voyez que les plus
grosses machines un son un gros carré et
effectivement c'est en chine qui a le
plus gros c'est un rectangle parce qu'
il fallait rentrer ça tous dans un grand
carré
mais la plus grosse machine est bien là
par contre vous avez aux etats-unis
beaucoup plus si on fait la somme des
puissances de calcul on est quand même
dans des choses beaucoup plus
importantes aux états unis en fait si
ton regard de cette carte
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
vous avez ici vous allez reconnaître les
nations vous avez la chine effectivement
vous allez aimer les états unis vous
avez le japon vous avez l'allemagne vous
allez la france si on fait le pendant
supercalculateurs et nations les plus
puissantes au niveau recherche
économique
on va retrouver à peu près des choses
équivalent c'est à dire que avoir des
super ordinateurs est aussi pas
simplement une affaire de prestige c'est
aussi un a dit un des indicateurs de
l'awb de l'état d'avancement d'un d'une
nation au niveau recherche comme au
niveau industrie comme au niveau
économique
alors effectivement si vous regardez
cette carte ici l'angleterre doit être
par là mais ce groupe ce quart est là et
la suisse qui a effectivement des
ambitions assez importante dans ce
domaine là et c'est quand même à noter
alors si on reprends ma ma loi de moore
au départ aujourd'hui on peut là la
prolonger de la même façon on est
toujours sur une et une échelle
logarithmique et donc ont peu content
compter le nombre d'opérations que fait
un calculateur et ça se compte en flop
donc nombre d'opérations par seconde
quelqu'un capable de faire un ordinateur
donc si on reprend la la courbe bas on
est parti de là ici vous avez à peu près
les seins les 500 premières machines
mondiale leur évolution
ici la machine la plus puissante et la
ici la somme des puissances de calcul
disponible au niveau mondial qui sont
reportés sur ces 500 premières machines
donc ça a c'est toujours on s'aperçoit
que la machine la plus puissante est
toujours celle qui représente la masse
de calcul la masse de possibles dit
calcule la plus importante mais ce qui
nous importe c'est quand même là la
courbe des 500 machines les plus
puissantes et et voir comment elle
évolue derrière donc c'est pas juste un
cas particulier
alors cette courbe donc flop vous voyez
qu'on en est déjà à des pointes à flop
et si vous voulez savoir ce que c'est
qu'un pata flop vous pouvez regarder ce
nombre et vous voyez le nombre de zéros
c'est le nombre d'opérations vous êtes
capable de faire une seconde avec une de
ses machines
mais ce qui est important ce qui est
intéressant sur cette courbe c'est que
regarder au début des années 2000
ici on était autour de 20 à 50 gigaflops
qui assez considérable eh ben on
imaginait que quand vous achetez un
ordinateur portable aujourd'hui que vous
mettez sur votre bureau vous êtes là
vous êtes à la capacité de calcul des
machines qu'on avait des super
ordinateurs des années 2000 vous voyez
légal certain laps de temps entre les
deux mais ce que ce dont je parle
aujourd'hui c'est ce que vous pourrez
disposer dans dix ans dans vos
ordinateurs portables alors si on reste
là effectivement je vous rappelle que
c'est une échelle log les puissances de
calcul sont faramineuses et on s'arrête
pas là c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on
est capable de prédire que l'évolution
des puissances de calcul va continuer la
recherche l'industrie tout se met en
place aujourd'hui pour aller vers ce
qu'on appelle l'exascale l'exascale à
chaque fois à chaque fois que je suis
passé de giga mais mes gars terrassé que
j'ai multiplié par mille l'exaspère
c'est encore multiplié par mille la
puissance de calcul disponible
aujourd'hui
et donc voilà et on prévoit d'aller vers
l'exascale en 2020 donc c'est dans
bientôt
alors quand même je reviens quand même
maintenant à nous à faire modélisation
et calcul je vous remet encore des
exemples ici puis sont intéressants ici
par exemple on simule directement la
combustion dans une cuillère le
fonctionnement d'un
potentiel d'un réacteur nucléaire de
type fusion avec ça des choses à faire
assez difficile à faire mes collègues
suisses eux essayent de modéliser
carrément un cerveau humain est ici vous
avez un réseau de neurones virtuel sur
un ordinateur
donc voilà à peu près tout ce qu'on peut
faire mais ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que effectivement on est sur cette
loi de moore mais c'est pas si simple
que ça c'est à dire que cette chose qui
étaient mécaniques qui venait de
l'industrie on l'a remplacé par la
multiplication des coeurs vous avez bien
compris
mais pour que cette multiplication des
coeurs on puisse en faire quelque chose
il faut être encore capable de paralyser
le calcul
or là où on avait mis l'humain out en
battant caspar avec un ordinateur on est
obligé de refaire intervenir et de
changer complètement la donne
alors on y arrive aujourd'hui c'est la
courbe verte ici vous avez la courbe de
la multiplication des coeurs vous voyez
qu'il ya des périodes stagnante la
puissance d'un ordinateur c'est pas
simplement mutés baker mais jusqu'à
maintenant on hésitait entre multiplier
les coeurs works accélérer la fréquence
d'horloge et donc des choses était comme
ça la courbe verte
ce sont des vraies applications c'est à
dire c'est sait calculer le temps de
calcul sur des vraies applications est
ce qu'on est capable effectivement de
suivre la courbe de progression c'est
pas parce que vous avez un super
ordinateur vous êtes capable de faire un
calcul qui va aller beaucoup plus vite
eu ce que je vais vous expliquer
et vous voyez que basescu rechange au
début des années 2000
un peu avant 2008 2009 ici la
progression des superordinateurs c'est
simplement par que l'ajout de coeur donc
c'est terminé tout le reste et vous
voyez que la courbe verte est elle aussi
capable de progresser et c'est là que je
veux un petit peu expliqué que cette
courbe verte qui est en fait comment
faire des calculs par elle elle reposait
pas que sur une partie mécanique
imaginez que bas comme on sort de des
fêtes de noël imaginez vous ayez une
colonne de chiffres additionnés suite à
emplettes jean et que vous avez fait
beaucoup à une grande famille et vous
avez sans chiffres additionnés ça vous
demande 99 opération à faire si vous
voulez faites comme je vais vous le dire
c'est à dire vous prenez le premier vous
additionnez avec le deuxième chiffre la
somme ou l'additionner avec le 3e et
ainsi de suite
donc vous allez arriver à faire beau
sans calcul de cette façon là le temps
que ça va vous apprendre c'est ce qu'on
va appeler votre temps de calcul
imaginez que vous êtes plus mam plus
malins et vous avez deux bons amis avec
vous alors qu'est ce que vous dites bien
vous donner 50 des premiers nombres à
votre premier ami et 50 des dés et cinq
autres août nombreux tout second ami et
vous leur demandez de faire la somme ils
vont la somme de la même façon ça leur
fera 49 opérations et vous donne le
résultat et vous avez plus qu à
additionner les deux résultats pour
obtenir le résultat que de la somme de
vos sens j ai donc si vous si vous vos
amis sont capables de calculer a même
testé vitesse que que vous c'est ce
qu'on va supposer
parce que vous allez être sympa avec eux
et bien vous allez vous avez été 2 fois
plus vite de cette manière là alors
effectivement on dit ah ben voilà c'est
ça le pari c'est pas très compliqué
maintenant imaginez que vous ayez 10
amis vous dire on va aller encore plus
vite
on va donner les dix premiers nombres à
mon premier et ainsi de suite vous allez
répartir vos 10 calcul sur vos dix amis
donc chacun va faire dix opérations donc
logiquement ça valait dix fois plus vite
que d'additionner les 100 premiers
laissant nombre au départ ont chacun
fait ses dix opérations et vous les
rangs et vous qu'est ce que vous avez
fait vous allez à faire 10 opérations
donc finalement vous avez pas accéléré
par 10 parce que derrière vous allez
faire encore dix opérations et donc là
vous comprenez qu'elle élimine les
mutations de cette agglo cette façon de
procéder et la difficulté du
parallélisme
c'est à dire que vous avez bien paralysé
vos opérations mais vous retrouvez avec
dix opérations supplémentaires à faire
c'est la partie s'étant siècle vous avez
oublié au départ donc vous faites ça et
finalement vous n'aurez accéléré que par
5 votre calcul puisque vous aurez fait
chacun raf et 10 opérations donc vous
avez divisé par 10 le temps de calcul
mais vous avez dix opérations
supplémentaires à faire donc vous avez
multiplié que par 5
si vous augmentez le nombre de vos amis
vous verrez que votre temps de calcul ne
va plus progresser même comment le
commencé à régresser à un moment donné
donc toute la difficulté est là c'est
qu'on a reporté les la progression de
l'industrie informatique vers vers les
hommes et la production de nouveaux le
sag au rythme qui sont derrière alors
hein c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui quand
je vous montre cette courbe verte elle
est très importante parce que là je vous
ai pris un cas où j'étais précis sur ma
part lisation 1 pour 1 10e prédire
qu'une fois que j'avais que j'ai atteint
à 10% après une fois que j'ai paralysé
mais mon système mais à 10 % près ben je
ne peux accélérer mon calcul que d'un
facteur 10 et donc je ne peux utiliser
que dix unités de calcul est donc jeu ça
me sert à rien d'avoir une machine à 2
millions de coeurs donc si on veut être
capable de utiliser ces machines à 2
millions de coeurs et certaines
personnes y arrive aujourd'hui il faut
être précis à 1 2 millionième prédire
que ce que vous avez négligé qui était
une fraction de votre temps de calcul
qui était une part pour deux millions eh
ben une fois que vous arrivez sur ces
machines là elle devient principal c'est
celle qui va vous coûter le la part la
plus la plus importante
alors une fois qu'on
on a compris ça et ça va finir ma montre
rapidement et ben on peut regarder ce
qu'on peut faire en simulation bas on
peut soit faire des expériences soit
6000 et alors c'est par exemple
aujourd'hui on essaye de se lancer dans
la production d'électricité avec des
éoliennes offshore pour tout ce qu'on va
être capable de faire dans un premier
temps c'est d'essayer de faire des parcs
éoliens offshore en pleine mer ça coûte
quand même des milliards juste pour
faire des essais pas pour faire de la
production
si on peut faire beaucoup de calculs et
des simulations numériques ça ne coûtera
que 1 centième voire un millième du coup
de une expérience réelle pour vous
montrer aussi où est-ce qu'on en est
aujourd'hui dans les calculs bas là je
vous montre si ça marche
deux vidéos et je bouge aurait pu ne pas
vous les montre en même temps et vous
demander où est le réel où est la
simulation donc si on est capable de
recommencer
vous voyez que en fait à droite c'est
purement la simulation numérique et de
la simulation numérique au sens où c'est
que de la pure résolution d'équations
et non pas la production d'une animation
de réalité virtuelle autre chose
l'aérodynamique et ça c'est pour vous
montrer pour qu'on a besoin
d'ordinateurs puissants
si je fais un calcul d'aérodynamique
autour d'une d'une formule 1 bah comme
tous les pilotes de formula sont assez
forts aujourd'hui sont même très très
fort les courses vont jouer à 1% près de
gains sur la vitesse donc 1% près de
gains sur la vitesse va dire qu'il faut
que je fasse des calculs qui soit précis
à 1% pour prétendre gagner une course
grâce à des calculs et d'un milk delà
d'une formule 1 donc j'ai à mes deux
collègues qui ajuste optimiser la forme
d'un rétroviseur sur une formule 1 et
ç'a permis pendant un certain temps de
faire gagner cette formule 1 par rapport
à une autre
vous voyez à peu près le niveau de
précision qu'on peut avoir
et souvent je reporte à à des
révolutions qui sont comme ça des
révolutions par seuil le seuil c'est
quoi rappeler pour ceux qui sont pas pas
3g
je dirais rappelez vous la le virage
entre la pellicule argentique et la
photo numérique aujourd'hui tout le
monde fait de la photo numérique vous
avez des super appareil photo sur vos
téléphones portables à un moment donné
il fallait que la le nombre de pixels
sur votre
sur votre capteur soit suffisamment
puissant pour suffisamment important
pour éliminer la photo argentique c'est
ce qui s'est passé dans les années au
début des années 2000 et c'est pour ça
que certains qui n'y croyaient pas comme
kodak ont disparu de la nature
aujourd'hui et basse un petit peu ça
c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois qu'on va
avoir des puissances de calcul
disponible nos modèles dont sony
réaliste et quand ils atteignent un
certain seuil de réalisme d'un seul coup
ça change complètement la donne au
niveau de ce qu'on peut en faire et au
niveau de la société
dans ce cadre là et tout ce que je veux
dire pour conclure et ben c'est que
effectivement dans la région nantaise et
à l'école centrale arrive un de ces
superordinateurs va nous permette
effectivement de faire des simulations
qu'on est capable de faire aujourd'hui
qui sont pas qui va pas être un
ordinateur de la taille de celui qu'on a
vu en chine mais qui sera intermédiaire
et qui nous permettra de faire cette
pyramide des moyennes calcul qui permet
aussi non seulement par d'avoir des
moyens de calcul mais aussi d'avoir des
gens qui commencent à travailler sur ces
machines et qui sont capables de faire
des choses nouvelles comme vous l'avez
compris on a effectivement on est
toujours sur la loi de moore des
progressions des temps de calcul
mais cette fois ci elle s'appuie de
nouveau sur nous pour pouvoir faire des
pour pour être capable de les utiliser
aujourd'hui et sur l'intérieur ans des
gens pour pouvoir les utiliser
donc je vous remercie